while the rest of america has moved on
from the pandemic and life returns to
normal president biden is alarming
people with talk of yet another one
here we do need more money but we don't
just need more money for vaccines for
children eventually we need more money
to plan for the second pandemic there's
going to be another pandemic we have to
think ahead
yeah but earth to biden we aren't going
back and even the liberals are ready to
let go the washington post reportedly
the latest company to crack down on
staff who were refusing a return to the
office
okay so
uh i remember greg that uh who was i
think was fouchy in 2017 in a speech he
was giving predicted that there would be
a pandemic now we've got biden
predicting there's going to be yet
another pandemic and then he talks about
money is this all about putting money in
big pharma or what is this about i think
you hit the nail on the head
that he is he's actually talking about
the future which i get but it's really
about the past like how do you prevent
something from happening you look at how
it started in the first place
bring up fouchy gain a function
maybe
biden should like he doesn't tell us his
actual plans why not launch
a real practical investigation into the
origins of the root causes of kovid
how vital would that be as opposed to
this monstrosity of a hearing that we
see every day that is just political
theater built
it's pure political theater it's for a
political aim it's not for anything else
in this case this is an aim for all
americans to find out why their loved
ones died we all know people who died
from this they're and no one's been
arrested there's been no i can't believe
that have millions and we have done
nothing to to discover
read matt ridley's book which is amazing
on covid it'll blow your mind but this
is just like 2019 2020 covid was
spreading and what we were doing
impeachment theater yeah exactly yeah
you know jesse the the interesting part
of it is that um we had a role to play
with gang of function uh funding it do
you think that has something to do with
not investigating the root causes of
covid i do
and fauci still supports gain a function
and fauci is still sending our money to
sloppy chinese labs even the chinese
can't even believe they're sending them
money they're like can you believe that
she's still sending us money okay pass
the bat i mean yes
why would you send these people money
after what they did to us and i think
greg to your point to your point thank
you when the republicans take the house
i'm not going to say red wave but when
they take the house they are going to
launch investigations into this and
they're going to subpoena fouchy he'll
probably be retired by then but they're
going to try to get to the bottom of
this i expect the pandemic to rise up
probably before each election going
forward and i think biden's just saying
this because he's so shell-shocked that
he missed omicron and delta that every
time he hears someone knock he thinks
it's another variant but judge who's
holding the money up anyway doesn't he
own congress the democrats aren't giving
him money it's the first time i've ever
heard that well you know the amazing
thing about china uh dana is that isn't
it biden who is talking about if he
hasn't already taken some of the tariffs
off chinese goods he's considering it
he's considering that he is partly
because there is an economic argument
that some people make that that has
caused inflation to go up and so when
you're looking at the toolkit of like
what are the possibilities i don't know
i think it would have a big difference
but that is one of the things but it's
kind of a schizophrenic response though
okay um don't you think okay i mean i
don't know i didn't really prepare for
chinese tariffs today um i would say
that remember let me handle this thing
that joe biden ran on getting rid of
covet that was what he was going to do
he's going to get covert under control
it is true that in the future there will
be another pandemic possibly in our
lifetimes maybe not but if you look back
in history yes that is what happens um
but what he could do with this money is
actually not just deal with where it
started but what did we do that worked
and what didn't work and i think we've
all agreed the lockdowns didn't work so
that's one of the things to put into the
little code book there when you have a
new pandemic is like look up in 50 years
like what happened oh they shut down the
economy and that did not work and kids
did not learn and that that's actually
an effective use of government funds
right now to put it together so it's
sort of like the after action report we
did after katrina that actually helped
so that you now have fema's much more
organized across the board to deal with
hurricanes and other natural disasters
that you can see that you can predict
before they happen final word i would so
warp speed what president trump did uh
appears to have worked from the
standpoint that these these vaccines
were safe we should think about that as
a platform going forward i think every
great leader whether you're a coach
whether you're a ceo whether you're a
politician or you're a producer or a
head of a network you think about what
works and what what doesn't work and
then you try to prepare for challenges
going forward you have to innovate
always so things we didn't have vaccines
therapeutics soap semiconductor chips
potato chips toilet paper we should
never face that kind of challenge again
that's where i hope some of the focus is
as well hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else